When I'm very much against as a person going through chemo radiation or surgery or whatever and because on the CT scan or
Pat's skin they don't see any
Rapidly replicated cells in there said your cancer-free. That is a lie
And I think that's that's a misinterpretation completely of the tests
They should be telling people you're you're doing really well your cancer free right now
But you should make lifestyle changes so this doesn't come back and get you to somebody who can appropriately do that
So it's you once you have cancer you're gonna you're just gonna think this is a chronically
This is a chronic disease and I'm just gonna be
Responsible for it make wise decisions about to constantly treat people ask me that all the time
Well, I got the right to have to use it the rest of my life. Well, hello
You had three weeks to live and now it's better year later. Why are you gonna stop?
You know, yeah, if you're gonna go to Las Vegas for two weeks or a vacation you don't have to bring it with anymore
But when you're home turn the thing up. Does it make sense? It's just making those lifestyle changes